ladies and gentlemen Jeremy Corbell and
special guest Mr Oliver tree this is my
honor to be here big time fan Jeremy is
it safe to say you're the World's
foremost UFO expert didn't think I'd
ever be professionally studying UFOs but
you know right tool for the right job
people say I'm a tool so there you go
but the first movies that you made made
it on Netflix yeah insane right like the
Bob Lazar movie so if anybody doesn't
know who Bob Lazar is he's a guy that
claims that he reversed engineered UFO
for the United States military in 1989
it came forward through George nap
that's how you know about Area 51 and
flying saucers in general Bob said he
worked on an alien spacecraft from
another world and the propulsion system
was what he was tasked on
examining and he said when you turn on
this gravity wave amplification machine
you couldn't bring your hands close to
it there were other weird things like
bringing a candle up towards it and it
was like frozen looking